grace is with us in detroit hey grace
welcome to the ramsay show
hi thank you for taking my call sure
what's up
um kind of lost here um i've been at my
job for 15 years
i absolutely despise it and i don't know
is it selfish of me
to be thinking about walking away from
it and trying
something new no why would you feel
selfish
why does that make you ask that question
i i guess i just get nervous about it i
i almost feel like i'm
institutionalized there and um
yeah that's true grace who's
who is relying on your income well i i
have two kids and my husband works as
well
yeah yeah so how much do you make
um it ranges from 70 to
100 but we work a lot overtime six days
a week
yeah and what what did how much your
husband mike
uh anywhere between um probably 100 112
give or take wow okay so wonderful
household income why
is it that over time you can't make a
decision to do something else that pays
as much
right i don't know i i'm just nervous
because
i don't have a degree or anything and i
thought about going back to school but
okay
but then we're losing income and then
well hold on i don't know
so grace i talk to people like this
every day that are in this and this is
all normal so don't feel bad about this
don't feel any shame
these are real emotions but it's because
you don't know
you don't even know what you don't know
or maybe you do
so i'm just curious what would you do
if you if you didn't have to worry about
getting qualified and you knew that you
could get hired you knew you would do
well any ideas that you
if you had the if you had the education
you could do anything you wanted to do
yeah what would you do i honestly i
really don't know
i i feel like i kind of lost myself you
know throughout the years
yeah yeah all right listen that's normal
too so i'm going to try to solve it
right here but i'm going to give you a
little construct but
but what you've got to ask yourself is
you you have to say
what would i do and keep asking yourself
what would i do and what would i do and
i promise you grace if you allow
yourself
to wonder like a child remember how he
used to wonder about everything
why don't you just allow yourself to
wonder what would i like to do but i'm
going to try to kick start this really
quick give you some ideas
who are the people you most want to help
if you could make a good living
and you were helping people with your
work who who would you want to try to
help anything pop in your head
um i really don't know
all right all right so here's the deal
when you lock up on this
here's no no it's okay here's what i
want you to do this is a quick homework
assignment
i want you to get out a piece of paper
tonight okay
while it's fresh and i want you to just
list out
you can type this up put on your phone i
don't care i want you to list out
the skills that you're really really
good at
i mean top level eights nines and maybe
a ten or two okay
i want you to just kind of just get
really aware of what you do well
then i want you to start to dream a
little bit and wonder go what kind of
work
do i think i would really enjoy doing
you haven't enjoyed working so long
your heart has actually been covered up
with so much
drudgery that you don't even think you
can enjoy work anymore is that true
yeah but i want you to get outside of
that and go what kind of work do i think
that i would enjoy
by the way you'll get some clues with
those skills you write down
because tens tends to be some examples
of some skills like detail-oriented
people-oriented so
yeah so uh let's let's work with her on
this so what are you what do you think
your top two or three skills
soft skills hard skills what would you
say if i interviewed everybody that
knows you what would they say
um i'm a detailed person okay um
i'm hard worker um
i i don't really know oh you sure you do
sure you do now when you say you're
detailed
that means you're pretty organized and
you like processes yes or no
oh yeah yeah structure you like
structure okay
give me an example of something you
might like to do that you've never done
that's involving details and structure
what pops to your mind don't worry about
a job title just the type of work
if you if you're good at details do you
like working with details
if you're good at processes do you like
working with processes
makes sense right right there you go
so i mean here's here's a weird thing
popped into my head so ken
i'm if you did that you okay
i just made this up in my head while she
was talking all right could be great or
while you were talking anyone
but um the uh if you like details and
you like organizing things
what if you do you like is it put a
smile on your face if like the garage is
organized or the uh
bedroom shelves are organized oh yeah
maybe maybe you open an organizing
company teach people how to do that
go into their homes and organize for
them okay
you heard of people doing that right
yeah yeah yeah
actually my daughter watches uh youtube
things on that yeah that's kind of like
a
woman whatever her name is it does that
stuff yeah but i mean you know you don't
have to you don't
you don't have to get a tv show all you
gotta do is just make money and i'm not
even sure that's the thing i'm just
saying that's an example
of something where just for just a
second you felt 10 pounds lighter
20 pounds lighter just for the idea of
doing that instead of doing what you're
doing
because it's a little bit closer to your
skills yeah and here's the deal grace
i think you have ideas and you're afraid
to say them and i'm not going to put you
on the spot here on the ramsay show
but i'm telling you you have ideas you
have wondered about stuff
and you're afraid to say it because
you're going i don't know if i'm too old
i don't know if i'm good enough i don't
know if i can get qualified
i don't know if i can replace my income
and i think that what you have to do is
you got to get to the point where you
begin to say what is it that i would do
and then we go look at it
let's say let's say she needs a degree
that takes two years to go get her some
certifications
if she started that 15 years ago she'd
already been 13 years into her new
career that's exactly right so start it
so start now here's why grace listen
grace you're making really good money 70
to 100 000
you could cash flow your way through
getting qualified
you can cash flow that and you don't
have to jump off of the ledge here
this is something you can do it is
doable
one thing i want you to do go to
kencoleman.com take the
career clarity guide it's going to allow
you a little bit more time and you're
not on the air you're under pressure
and you walk through the exercise and
then if you're still stuck
call me on the ken coleman show i think
the idea is there dave
here's what i've seen a lot people have
thoughts
and and yet what they do is they go oh
that's a thought but it's
it's not doable or it's going to cost
too much or
if i fail we're going to live under a
bridge there's so many fears and doubts
that immediately start to go like this
they fire like firecrackers
you know in our head and we're like oh i
can't do that and we've got to get to
the point where we say hey
what would i love to do what what
results does this work create and then i
ask myself well you say do i actually
have the talent
maybe not right now but is it a skill a
learnable skill
most of the time the answer is yes and
then we say all right
what do i have to learn what do i have
to do how much is it going to cost
how long is it going to take based on my
financial reality
those four qualifying questions dave
create a plan
don't look up 15 years no from now and
not having started
no it's never stuck because you're not
stuck
no not making this kind of income you're
not stuck they're combined income she
can cash flow any
on this income you're not stuck but you
don't have to do that you can you can
use this income to make the transition
that's what you should do gently and
wisely but you need to take the first
few steps
in the next few weeks and step one is go
to kencoleman.com and take the career
assessment
and that will make a big what would you
call it the it's the career clarity
guide
cure career and it's free it's
absolutely free ken coleman.com
and it'll really begin to give you some
answers and you begin to see
ideas or verify some thoughts that
you've had